we talked about you growing up in West
Virginia yes and I was thinking about
this today you grow up in West Virginia
and now you live here almost heaven
almost happy almost heaven and you grew
up in Los Angeles is this place country
enough for you because you really grew
up in the country I mean is this country
enough it's more country I think then
people think you know what I mean it is
like you can have a big garden one thing
I love about living in LA is you can
grow so much stuff like as soon as you
move here there's a lemon tree in your
yard and you just want an orange tree
and this year we grew peanuts and I'll
bring peanuts at yes do you think they
grow on a tree or in the ground I'm
curious I think they grow on the ground
oh they do
I like your class miss Garner
the best of all the class so yes we we
do we have stuff as a matter of fact
where we live that we're on a hill and
the this is country for you okay so down
the sides of the hill we have oh this IV
look really old IV that's been there
forever and there we realized that there
were rats living in the ivy and it
started to feel like we need to deal
with this but it was gonna be expensive
to tear out so my husband was going on
location and I said just go I'll take
care of it don't worry I've got it I
found an inexpensive way to take care of
the ivy I brought a picture what do you
do I think there's let's see a picture
here that's a picture of it looks like
goats that's my house what is not your
house I rented a herd of goats wait what
are you talking about did you bury two
been on location and said it was like
his first day on the Batman set and I
sent him that picture and said honey I'm
taking care of the ivy what was his
response he's on the Batman set and he's
just knows that you're gonna what call
like a pest exterminator and you that's
a lot that's a lot of ghosts 120 goats
and we had a party we called it the
running of the goats and they all showed
up and we invited a bunch of kids and we
herded them from the driveway to the ivy
it was so much it's a really you need to
help friends need to help me more
because I don't understand what are the
goats do the ghosts eat oh yeah okay I
thought the goats had shovels
I don't know I know about peanuts but I
don't know what goats do they wore so
many kind of skittering down I think
towards your house you know we actually
I live near you and I did see about 800
rats they rang my bell and I opened the
door and they just came in on so so the
goats ate all the rats no idea and then
they went away so that problem was taken
care of I'd be taken care of genius way
but number but now you have 120 goats
hanging out right you know what they're
loud goats are loud and at night they're
pretty docile they're fairly quiet but
every now and then there was one that
would be right under my bedroom window
and it would go mama did they say mama
do you think in the books they say Mae
but in real life they say mama thank God
I think this was me
how does it really at the window and you
see me there in the dark I look for the
size of your swoop that is crazy to me
because there is a lot of wildlife you
know in in our part of town I hear
chickens yes like a rooster in the
morning I know then at night I hear
coyotes indeed people say there are
bobcats I've always wanted to go out at
night on my bike and fight a bobcat you
shouldn't do that that's if you have
that impulse call I will really able to
talk to you I'll write a goat out at
night and just skates them down
that's absolutely did you have footage I
think you have footage yeah which of the
goats I think we do know oh my god
looks like they're just do you know what
why wouldn't he come back after that a
goat herder did not tell me that IV
grows back we have a full Hill I'm
waiting for Benton notice that it all
how fast is it grow back it's back now
okay yeah you should have Andy and I and
the studio audience will come will eat
the ivy or you will just chop it all
down for you not a problem you don't
need the goats next
you